This table is showing you the lines of code that the
designers of Xen hypervisor had to change
in the native operating systems. The two native operating systems that they
implemented on top of Xen hypervisor are Linux and Windows XP. And you see
that, in the case of Linux, for instance, the total amount of the original
code base that had to be changed is just about 1%, 1.36%. And in the case
of XP, it is miniscule, almost an annoyance. So in other words, even though,
in para virtualization we have to modify the operating system to run on top of
the hypervisor, the amount of code change that has to be done in the operating
system in order to make it run on top of the hypervisor. Can be bound to a
very small percentage of the total code base
of the original operating system. Which is good news.